have you ever thought about standing for
a community board it is a great way to
serve your community and with the local
body elections coming up we're fishing
for new candidates so what's involved
well if elected the decisions and
recommendations you make will benefit
your local community you'll attend
monthly meetings community events and
maybe involve with various community
groups depending on your interests and
availability you can expect to spend
three to five hours a week in the role
so make a difference nominations are
open now grab the form or find out more
at Waimakariri dot govt T dot n z4 /
vote 2019
[Music]